just over a day after the u.s. missile
strut tack in Syria the tension between
America and Russia is escalating while
the u.s. threatens more pressure on
Syria Syria's ally Russia is calling the
strike an act of an aggression that
didn't just damage an airfield but
us-russia relations as well Holly
Williams has the latest from Istanbul
Turkey Holly good morning good morning
the US missile strikes were in
retaliation for a suspected chemical
attack and inflicted serious damage on
one of Syria's most important air bases
59 Tomahawk cruise missiles were
launched by the u.s. from two ships in
the Mediterranean Sea
targeting chiraq airbase in western
Syria from where it's thought the Syrian
regime launched a chemical attack on
Tuesday US officials estimate 20
russian-made aircraft belonging to the
regime were destroyed ammunition dumps
and radars were also hit the Syrian
regime called it a barbaric act of
flagrant aggression and claims it
doesn't possess chemical weapons it's
close ally Russia called the missile
strikes a violation of international law
the regime and Russia both deny there
was a chemical attack on the town of hon
Shaheen an atrocity that left people
gasping for breath foaming at the mouth
and suffocating to death
all telltale signs consistent with
exposure to a toxic nerve agent Russia
and the regime claimed a conventional
regime airstrike like this
he took chemical weapons facility
operated by their enemy Syria's rebel
forces but a conventional stripe say
experts would disappoint those chemicals
not disburse them in Honshu hoon they've
buried their dead and many residents
have now fled some who have remained say
the US missile strikes aren't enough
there should be more so we don't get hit
again I said this man to avoid
retaliation with another chemical attack
Sharat is just one of several Syrian
regime air bases and the regime is
continuing to carry out airstrikes
including one today on Han Jieun
according to opposition activists Alex
Holly Williams in Istanbul thanks Holly